the Joe Rogan experience when I was a
playboy I wrote about like I had this
experience so I was like the second wife
I wasn't a wife but I was a second in an
open marriage and all the guys think
they're gonna be that guy and it's like
the I was reading this book and I forget
which book it was or something and said
actually that men who had multiple wives
and women had to start like not hogging
all the women because it was causing so
much strife within the Leki tribes yeah
Jordan Peterson talks about that too
that that's one of the problem with in
cells is that there's the men like the
alpha man like Jason Momoa of the world
they have you know if they wanted to we
could have a gang of women yeah other
guys
but I kind of honestly I kind of liked
this situation the guy was so alpha and
it almost took two women to like balance
them out and from my perspective I was
like I want a wife I me as a wife would
want a wife too I would want someone
else like we it was so like we did the
gardening and like sure this work outfit
it didn't work out for that like like a
couple nights no no is it was a while
did you see the king of Thailand like
you formally got rid of his concubine
what did he call he like royal mistress
royal mistress
yeah concubine would be a [ __ ] border
yeah a little old school old school the
same thing I think I'm not sure well
thank you bye Anne has a flair royal
mistress that was actually like she had
rank in the military oh yeah and she
apparently disrespected the Queen so you
had to shut her down and he had to strip
her of her power oh and I was Roberto
yeah there's like piss on her what's
happening when you go to tiny you cannot
talk [ __ ] ever there it is there's the
for King I don't know how to say his
name
very good long corn comes no
responsibility at all well so he has
this with that his wife's let me see
that
what is the article the king of Thailand
how to say that / M
orly I've never seen that word ever have
you ever seen that word you're a writer
no I don't peremptorily ramped orally as
that dismisses his official mistress
I've known that she was talking to you
about the wife she disrespected the wife
kick rocks [ __ ] what does it mean I
don't know
look at her name well now I have to I'm
gonna be I look up every word I don't
know that your attitude misbehavior and
disloyal to these were among the
failings of try saying her name si an EE
in eighty seen Sydney at and here's the
big one wo n GV AG AI r AP Wow d I I
don't even try that one long detailed in
a scathing royal statement on October
21st
apparently the mistress she allowed
herself to the same state as the Queen
of course yeah that was ultimately why
it didn't work out really well number
one I didn't want to be number one
because that has a lot more
responsibilities and I'm not really that
type a but I didn't feel like I felt
like everyone's needs were being I was
like hey are you okay are you okay and
no one was like hey is Bridget okay so I
felt like that my my needs were the ones
that got pushed aside pushed aside yeah
well you can call that [ __ ] show you we
can start a little meeting you and that
whatever name it was really just one of
those things I'm such a writer and so
curious but on this she was just made
that position in July it was the first
time it was done in over a century um so
she lost it very quickly that's really
fast she basically was like yo I want to
be number one after like a month alright
that's a little entitled she gave it a
shot
calm down what do you think that I state
herself before the king and queen a
former flight attendant who he married
in May
[Applause]